our next guests were first cram
daughters who became first daughters but
before it all they were sisters first
Jenna Bush Hager and Barbara Bush write
about their unbreakable bond and what it
was like growing up in the public eye
and they're touching new memoir sisters
first stories from our wild and
wonderful life we are thrilled to have
them here with us on the five fantastic
- have you already been getting broken
in right before yes enter waters world
so I have to ask you did you guys we
talked about this say like for a few
years and did you say I'm gonna wait
till a certain period of time passed or
you were of a certain age before you
decided to work and collaborate on this
together well we didn't always dream of
writing a book because we it's not a
typical political memoir that's we're
too young for that
I think but when I had my second baby
girl my mom had the thought of sending a
baby picture of the two of us - Mila my
oldest and so that we could talk about
the awesomeness it is to have a sister
and the more we talked to Mila about
that the more we sort of talked about
our narrative and realized that in
awkward moments like some of the ones
you showed on Inauguration or normal
everyday moments having each other was
such a gift well speaking of awkward
moments the book for me and she takes my
pen and she says what's your name again
since you're a twin I read the book
twice and I wanted to hear both of your
voices not everybody on this table read
the whole book kill me let's kill me I
wanted to ask I know you guys got in
trouble when you guys were at the White
House and that was I was mostly you was
that what was it like what was it like
you know getting in trouble when you had
that kind of spotlight on you well it
wasn't always that much fun but at the
same time I'm so lucky we had the
parents we did because they allowed us
to be ourselves there was maybe you had
a level of perfection for us
sorry we didn't our parents didn't make
us feel that way which is a blessing
because I do think that kids whether
you're the president's children are not
are allowed to make mistakes but you
didn't really get in I mean like all
things being said it wasn't that big a
trouble before 21 Jena everybody knows
that I want to hear you tell the story
about what it was like when your dad
told you that he was going to run for
president and what you thought well we
didn't react very well we made a public
apology six days ago to her father
reaction we we were 16 we feel terrible
we burst into tears at the exact same
moment I was only twins can yes a secret
magic twin power and we told him he was
gonna lose and then we told him he was
gonna ruin our life but we none of which
happened oh we don't we realize the
privilege it is to live history's hey so
I watched a lot of horror movies and
horror movies are where you get a lot of
the eternal truths and one of the
eternal truth there's a Twins generally
female twins are evil whenever they show
up in a horror movie they always sing
together they can read each other's
minds so I was curious which one of you
is the evil twin which one would either
no no no and I bet there was some
sibling rivalry here there was a point
where you hated each other correct no no
he had a rocky 13 right there yeah but
we we never hated each other I think
luckily because we weren't compared
except for again by people that didn't
know us but our parents did you guys
have bunk beds no bump it we didn't have
twin beds next to each other well that's
cool twin beds because we're twins yeah
[Music]
so I think yo you're the evil twin why
do you think so you're you're more quiet
she talks and then you do evil things in
the back I don't know I'm scared
personally I don't want to end up in a
well
[Laughter]
who do you like more gutfeld or me you I
thought there were two interesting
things there for me one was and I know
your grandmother and your grandmother is
in this story finds the two of you in
the White House basement bowling and
won't you tell the story well we wanted
to order a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich the White House before we were
seven we heard it had a bowling alley so
we went there we picked there was a
phone on the wall so we picked it up
that's we called we ordered a peanut
butter and jelly and then we were
waiting for it and it wasn't the peanut
butter and jelly it was our grandmother
okay who came down and she said under no
circumstances will you order food here
this is that not a hotel this is a
temporary house and you will treat it
with respect so we never ordered people
we never know what it tasted well is for
you named for your grandma okay which is
this amazing moment because we're going
through all the sexual harassment stuff
in America today so you're at dinner
with Berlusconi and your mom tell him
what happens well it was lunch and he
showed a lot of affection and told me
that I should have children with his son
and better yet with him but I was with
the entire u.s. Olympics Committee and
my mother so I didn't feel threatened in
any way but I did think it was shocking
it was just one moment that happened
what do you say to a guy in this well I
you can't this is it could be like this
could be a diplomatic flare-up if you
say the wrong thing to him well everyone
with me sort of luckily everyone
protected me and laughed and made jokes
in terms of it being ridiculous say my
father will bomb it'll all right